les poussines mayotte ont de nouveau
défié le pouvoir russe aujourd'hui à
sotchi
elles ont tenté de livrer un concert
improvisé sur le site olympique de nos
représentations interrompu par les coups
de fouets de cosaques une force
policière auxiliaire de membres du
groupe avaient été arrêtés puis relâchés
hier sans qu'aucune accusation ne soit
portée contre elle ces deux militantes
avaient été libérés en décembre des
prisons russes après y avoir passé près
de deux ans pour avoir critiqué vladimir
poutine
les athlètes ukrainien qui participent
aux jeux de sotchi se disent
profondément bouleversée par les
événements tragiques qui se déroulent
dans leur pays ils ont demandé au comité
international olympique
l'autorisation de porter un brassard
noir en hommage aux victimes des
affrontements de kiev
une demande refusée en vertu de la
neutralité olympique
c'est le philosophe français bernard
henri lévy veut que sotchi se
souviennent des morts de la place de
l'indépendance de kiev
il lance un appel au boycott de la
cérémonie de fermeture des jeux
olympiques
dans une lettre publiée dans le journal
le monde ils dénoncent les deux visages
de vladimir poutine
d'un côté le dieu du stade qui reçoit le
monde avec splendeur et de l'autre le
politicien retors qui manipule le
gouvernement ukrainien
bernard henri lévy s'est rendu la
semaine dernière à kiev afin d'appuyer
les manifestants